it's me get down get over here get over
here get down
get down get down who's in there I don't
know there's somebody in there in that
room get down stay right here
who fired shots
and whose weapon is this all right I put
it down for you
I had to I was like
stay here say hello please
stay here don't move
what is going on
I'm literally with my wife
this car is the white Mercedes it's the
way Mercedes yours
[Music]
your qru North Korea
stay right there
[Applause]
because you can literally climb right
there and go through everything
man you all right
stand by the car just don't get in the
car don't leave okay
at all times okay all right
now I'm in trouble
they just disappeared
and there was how many you said four
four
all right just go ahead and get all the
info right now oh the last thing I want
to do is ever just charge my weapon
so this is your firearm oh yeah license
not her she's saying that she's I don't
know she's a fire I fired
last thing I ever want to do man is
I couldn't see the the actual scene
color man I was like this behind the
door I gave warning warning the warning
I put down everything I love man
everything I love
and give me your date of birth
imagine I'm just there with my wife we
have four kids I get it your kids are
all up there too oh no imagine what if
they came from both boys
you know I don't know I didn't know but
nobody's there I wouldn't make the way
that boxing but no like my studio it was
almost I was scared I was scared
I have to just relax okay well my
heart's just beating because
but at the end when she called I thought
they were going to come and Rush us like
so it was just kind of scary you know
and you said it happened 20 minutes ago
it's a good time we got here no why
didn't you call us
she was scared but yeah she was only
good I said do not shoot babe I'm giving
a morning I don't want her to go so you
called 9-1-1 yeah like within the three
minutes or four minutes
oh
that moment happens you don't know what
to do
you know but I know I did the right
thing that they taught me in class we
just gave a warning I assuming they're
running the web
with me he said what it's registered
do I get in trouble for the taking my
business
I didn't shoot like your hair or nothing
I just
gave warnings
I get it I just I I'm explaining to you
because you understand me
okay
all right baby it's okay
sorry it's a nasty one I know honey
not okay
let's just get the salt thing
straightened out no I know she didn't
it's it's a tactic we separate you guys
from your stories okay so just you know
we don't need you getting upset just
relax okay and that's all
cooperate and everything will go down
just fine that's all there is to it
it's just like the thing that was last
week was it the fight or nothing was
just
the guy that will do my steps
doesn't mean how to represent my son no
I understand yeah it's all right
that's why I don't know I don't know who
I don't know who you were never had a
problem like that ever I know
I'll do everybody know where your studio
is I'm sure by now yeah
I'm sure they were scoping it out
because we had just went to CVS you
didn't see any cars leave he didn't get
any tags you didn't run out so one night
that we didn't have the kids
my wife didn't do nothing saw me at the
Two Shots we got you don't worry I would
never lie to especially you
stop saying sorry no because it's like I
I I know that's annoying for you guys to
come out here especially if you couldn't
catch somebody
you know but I know for sure what I saw
and I know she saw it you know they were
right there behind him and I would love
to show you because it was like
literally like
I literally bought that exact door for
that like not that's ever happened you
know
most important thing you can do is just
why you're telling it don't change your
story in any way shape or form and be
cooperative with the police and there's
not going to be any issues you know
take a ride you take a ride I mean I
don't know
all right
yeah
one thing over and over and over that's
fine
um Davey's coming so I need you to stay
here is this your car
it is do you have any weapons in the car
what do you have
yeah it was I keep that from a rapper I
like people I'm a Target dude so let me
ask you is this your car oh yeah and the
weapon in the back belongs to you yeah
I'm licensed no I know but I'm saying I
thought you said you belongs to a rapper
no I'm a rapper oh yeah yeah I know that
yeah okay all right man I just want to
make my four kids every day I get three
warnings I literally said it I said I
don't want to shoot you guys man I told
my wife stay back you have any video
um I'm sure yeah make sure I have a
video I can show you inside the place
no no I'm just saying because we need to
gather information and they need to
check because if we have subjects we
need to find out who they are
doing that there ain't no that's not my
that's not my property
that's not my property
there's four divisions okay yeah that
room that looks like demolished that
where you said that they went through
that's not your property
she was one of the shoes I said do not I
got you baby
you know I gave orange I knew I knew
when I see this class they tell you it's
just like if somebody right now with the
streets and they and they you know you
you got you're not in life and danger
but he's going to grab his weapon you
give a warning listen I don't want to
take your life I'm armed you know I
always give a warning so it's better
report all right
you gotta take me out all right listen I
know you gotta do your job and I'll go
I'll go because I know in my heart
as if I was defending my wife and myself
I was scared
my rappers die every day I know they do
I know
who is the most recent one to pass
yeah
and then he killed the people that don't
even know
money money money money
the last thing I won't like you to see
my that type of music you know
my wife
you know
anybody who can say that I shared in
that moment is alive
what's that but if anybody says they're
ever still not scared in that type of
moment they're lying oh of course that
shit was mad scared man of course
you know that okay give me uh
a crime scene page so we need to fill
out who comes in and out
I can use this
no no no no we have a page
all right
let's see if yesterday we're parked
there and then
we're gonna eat and she changed her mind
and then we go upstairs and we're gonna
watch a movie and then no just happened
bro this is so quick
I almost wish that we just went home
I wish they robbed the places that's
what they were here for honestly bro
now there's a room we could not check it
was locked
no that's the studio booth I know it was
locked so we can't tell if anybody was
always ready for you I already got it
done keep it
it's always locked yeah that's my rumors
so there's no way that somebody's there
okay
okay just wait here I'll go over there
they're detaining you that's it
that's all good you're being detained
right now that's what this means right
while we're conducting an investigation
I get it because you're allowed to like
defend your business right
I think so
my wife cried
all right
about nothing yeah I know I know yep
okay why is Texas here's gonna talk to
your wife then he's gonna come talk to
you you don't have keys to the car right
now right yeah all right it's open
car no no no your car is open this is my
wife's car it's under my name no no but
he said open or close yeah
you have access to the trunk
yeah but why why so I could secure the
weapons they're going to come in
the one that was in the trunk hey you
guys can keep the weather
the woman in the trunk right oh no you
got it all too yeah no no we just need
to secure the scene so if you can open
the trunk
all right go ahead you can open it's
your part right I know but all right put
it on the floor for you oh that's fine
just tell me where it is you don't have
to touch it
it's your car
all the way back here all the way in the
back all right
foreign
foreign
there were people in your place yeah you
defended yourself and we need to get as
much information you have done the same
thing because you'll have people coming
at me with firearms and Innovations of
properties I was honestly really scared
because well I'm outnumbered just
fighting there dude you know
I don't know what I don't have problems
with nobody else
that's to scare you then so far and
obviously you have a water bottle right
okay
all right
check on the wine behind the seat
the 24 behind the hair seat my wife okay
she's still scared behind her seat
there's another one behind her seat
money for that one
now we told her that she wants to sit in
the car and secondly but she said she'd
rather seat outside to it starting
all right that shit was scary
came in you were already in the studio
or you're coming from home yeah we were
here with this yes so in between the Gap
that you went to the CVS to come back
that's when they came in yeah I don't
even know how long you're with who knows
and when you came you open it with your
key everything was locked oh I I so I
used the code if the one tied back the
one time I didn't lock it with the key
but
you you don't know any of them no I I
know the whole revived right it's here
okay the old life bro I don't got a
problem with nobody bro
um it's the expensive equipment you know
so
I
I prepare my head be expecting me that
because the top of those Studios
and the one thing that I actually spent
because we didn't have our kids today so
I wanted to watch movies with her so
we just bought a house yesterday what is
it that uh you bought a house yesterday
yeah Naples bro congratulations
shit goes good boom that's far yeah I'm
tired of Miami dude
do your planning on relocating the
business
bro are you going to be driving back and
forth that's great music bro
it ain't working on my family's life
brother
like I said luckily it looks like nobody
got hurt
you guys are okay you know I'm allowed
to to defend my business of course your
business your home yourself I'm sorry
for this I know you don't want to be
doing this shit no more I mean this is
our I'm here we're 24 hours
if this was a police officer that did it
we still have to go through the whole of
course because we have procedures
retired but he did a six crime okay
hold on
just uh
foreign
[Music]
you know like uh
to be aware of that
what are we talking about like what
happened there like you wanna know what
happened here yeah we're just we're
doing an investigation something
happened this morning and we're just
investigating it
so you have to just stand by a little
bit and then once this is clear we can
let you
inside
okay
[Applause]
we're investigating it right now okay so
I I'm gonna work here in this no dude we
no one can go into the building right
now okay
okay you understand how long do you
think
you want to put it back in and put it
yeah because it's going to disassemble
it and then if the bottom goes then I
don't know how to this is not an AR
foreign
[Music]
are you on that
all right yeah right you're recording
I'm doing okay good that's what no we
need to make sure we're talking to Kathy
so I'm gonna have to turn this back on
okay just make sure you keep an eye on
her morning
sweet hey
upstairs whose car is that right there
yeah
my wife
Dave's with the husband at the station
okay
no
nothing
only if you brought it
oh yeah
my camera is off because after the
scene's secure
I said I could turn mine off anyways I
have to be back on the road
I'm gonna saw well you're dealing with
back and forth I'm gonna
go around
take care of the other stuff
crime scene log has to be put in a crime
scene yeah okay the times and everything
I got it on there you already put Grime
so he went in yeah time and everything
told me when I went in at the time and
everything
we all we all got all the time correctly
from the dispatch and all that you're
winning at 7 15.
sure
anybody else aside from that lady came
from about the front door
I'm gonna go to the front
okay
you know we're in the store let me know
we were calling you but you didn't
answer your phone
everything's good though
no they're just invest during
investigation it's all good
but that thing is safe don't worry about
it
it's safe don't worry about it
everything's good
inside
the building
take care
thanks
foreign
[Music]
she's in there
foreign
[Music]
okay all right and then just determine
if there's any other cameras in the area
I'm not visiting cameras right here but
that would help us out okay
so not if I'm start off with that one
over there and then over here cat you
can sit in your car if you want are you
sure yeah
anybody coming in and out of you know
coming
[Applause]
um
nice and cool
questions does your camera in the back
does it work
um how long is every car 24 hours I'm
not sure I would have to ask out the
Lazarus and she's on vacation
the office manager or
you know like seven hours difference
from me right now seven hours
difference between
time so she is later or earlier she's
later seven hours ahead of time
I can send her a message and see how
she respond and then after
um
that was the
two quick access it's on site here or is
it offside
[Music]
until the case we need to access we
gotta contact her or
um I what I likely um but I will try and
reach out to her and see um because then
sometimes she doesn't have she's not in
service area so I have to email her and
wait for her to
hurt because we we had an issue happen
and we just need to
verified check yeah check the cameras
huh yeah we throw it safe
it's too early
yep
how are you
know where the um I guess the camera
room is now
um yes it's enough for Lazarus office is
there a way you can see if it's actually
if it's on
the screen that's there I can take a
look um I know they moved it recently
it comes on but there's nothing on the
screen so I have to find out so it
doesn't say like recording no it just
says no signal right now that doesn't
mean that the camera itself is not
recorded so I have to ask her because
she have all the remotes and all yes
okay I'll give you the detective's name
okay and she just let him know um
when you can have access okay to do a
recording so we can just verify an
incident
okay thank you all right have a good day
where conducting an investigation right
now oh okay because you know I'm a
landline
everyone called me okay just an
investigation yeah okay okay
[Music]
who has access to security cameras in
the back do they work in the back do you
know okay
um
uh what our cameras display so I just
see it like actively as it happened
so I guess like this is
our view of the back this is like the
parking along the back of the building
this is the front front
this is the parking on the back of the
building this is like the side
okay let me um
so if you don't have access to it I
guess we need a recording yeah if we
needed a copy of a recording
um who would probably have access is uh
we had one of our employees Greg I could
ask him if I think that he'd be the
person that would happen he's he's a
contact person
um
I would that's uh let me let me double
check but I think I think so
if we had a incident happened on the
other side and we just the camera's
cover the area so we need a good morning
Church By the Sea hi Barbara do you know
who has access to the security footage
like the recordings of the security
footage
oh uh maybe Greg or maybe uh Jeff do you
know if Greg is in the building at the
moment yeah he's in the building you
want me to tell him to come up yes
please okay all right
I'm gonna get him right now thank you
is everything all right yeah
everything's good it says speed
had an Instagram we just need to verify
it and that's like a weakness okay yeah
of course
um he'll be coming up to the front right
now
is she like the I.T guy or
awesome you should probably or at least
okay thank you
so defending on the angle where exactly
in the angle I don't have to see which
of the three or he needs more than one
angle and then just basically I need a
contact person for the detective to
contact
so he can come and get the footage as
well okay can I use his name or uh yeah
you can
is that fine to give him your name as a
contact
uh yeah who's gonna get the footage okay
what do you need his just his name his
name name and phone numbers stuff like
that and I'll give it a detectives there
okay that would be perfect thank you so
much
good morning Greg yeah how you doing
Greg I'm off to Wilson Bay Harbor ah
like she explained we had Vincent to
happen in the back yeah and we just want
to
see the food is just a collaborate the
story
this evening I have three cameras in the
back do you know where and their angle
different I mean that's all up to the
detective let me just get your
information yeah sure and then um he'll
contact you
okay
everything is fine it's just that you
know yeah it helps out when you have
security for it you know yeah you see
the news they always know my new videos
is starting now so
he's gonna get all gather all the
information interview people stuff like
that yeah all right all right thank you
thanks again
you too
Dad has a good view
and okay both have to use yeah that
that's kind of
Hold Back Alley
top
the doctor so no one has roofs here they
always show
street level
clear camera's complete turn off
recording